1, 2, 3.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) 1, 2, 3. 1, 2, 3.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) 1, 2, 3. 1 2, 3. Sometimes, things aren't what you think they are, and people aren't who you think they are. That's what we're talking about today. I'm Ira Glass.
That is really weird, to hear you do that.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm here. This is actually Ira Glass. I'm sitting here with Fred Armisen.
Hi.
Hi-- who's probably best known for Saturday Night Live, but also Portlandia. And I knew that you had worked up an imitation of me because we just happened to meet once.
Yeah.
And then you said something like, but you're not famous enough, so I have no use for this on television.
[LAUGHS]
I might have said that exactly.
Yeah, and-- yeah.
Well, after that, this writer at SNL, Christine Nangle and I, we figured out a way to turn it into a sketch that we could put on Weekend Update, the news segment on Saturday Night Live. By chance, NPR came up in the news. I think this was around the time that they were talking about cutting some of the funding.
Here to comment on NPR'S troubles, the host of This American Life, Ira Glass.
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
So I came out, and I'm wearing your glasses and a wig to look like you.
It's This American Life.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm Ira Glass. Act 1. I was thinking the other day--
And the joke being that you were interviewing people at "Weekend Update."
Ira, look, you can't bring other people on as your guests. You're my guest. It's just, your CEO just resigned. And now the Republican budget proposes cutting your funding completely. I mean, aren't you afraid that NPR might start laying people off?
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Act 2.
Oh, boy.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Laid off? No guts?
So this never made it to air. This is just the recording from the dress rehearsal. Why didn't it make it to air?
Who knows? It might have been a little unwieldy.
So if people want to watch that, the entire video, we have a link at our website. Anyway, so we invited you here today because the theme of this week's show is doppelgangers. The show is about doppelgangers, about people who are doubles or lookalikes. And I realized that because you had worked up this imitation, you could co-host as my doppelganger in this room, in this studio, during this broadcast. This is an audience who will actually know who you're playing.
Yes, this is the right venue for it.
So if you're ready, that's what we'll do.
Sure. And another way to look at it is, you're co-hosting with me, that this is my show.
Exactly.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And that's what we're talking about today. I'm Ira Glass.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so let's go to this copy. So we have some copy for today. OK. That's this one. And let's go to there. And let's just-- why don't you start?
OK. (IMITATING IRA GLASS) Today on our show-- today on our show.
Let me think. I'm just thinking about how I would do it. I would go, today on our show--
Oh, yes. That's better. OK. (IMITATING IRA GLASS) Today on our show--
We have two stories of supposed doppelgangers.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) --we have two stories of supposed doppelgangers. And we try to figure out the truth of them.
Do I sound that nasal?
Maybe.
And we try to figure out the truth of them.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And we try to figure out the truth of them.
One concerns two men who've never met--
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) The other, two animals who never meet.
I think you should do the next part because it's so-- do you want to hear me do it first? Or do you just want to do it? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Distributed by Public Radio International.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel like a Muppet. Why does it make me feel like a Muppet, Fred? [LAUGHTER] Seriously, why--
I think you could be a Muppet. I don't know why they don't have a Muppet of you.
From WBEZ Chicago, It's This American Life--
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life--
--distributed by Public Radio International.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) --distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
And I'm Ira Glass.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
So Fred, you want to start Act 1?
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) OK, Act 1, Dead Ringer. We start today with a story of physical resemblance, not of a person, but of a food.
A quick warning that if you're squeamish or averse to graphic images of food, there's going to be some of that in this report. Here's Ben Calhoun.
I first heard about this whole thing in an email. It came from a listener, a woman named Emily Rancer. She works in the food industry.
And the letter Emily wrote was about a story she'd heard from a farmer. The farmer who told her this is apparently a person of some standing in the pork industry. And admittedly, I don't know the first thing about the pork industry, but he's in charge of a pork-producing operation that spans several states.
The story he told Emily went something like this, a while ago, he was visiting a pork processing plant in Oklahoma. He's walking through it with a friend, a guy who managed the plant, actually. And at some point, he saw boxes stacked on the floor, labeled "artificial calamari."
He stood there, wondering for a second. And then he asked his friend, what's artificial calamari? Bung, his friend replied. It's hog rectum, rectum that would be sliced into rings, deep fried, and boom, there you have it.
OK, if I can, let me just narrate for you what this would mean. It would mean that in restaurants everywhere, right this second, people are squeezing lemon wedges over crispy, golden rings, and dipping the rings into marinara sauce, and they're eating hog rectum.
Now, they're chewing, satisfied, and deeply clueless. It's payback. It's payback for our blissful ignorance about where our food comes from and how it gets to us. It's amazing. And it's perfect.
But it also seems like it couldn't possibly be true. So I called up the farmer to talk to him personally. I wanted to hear it firsthand. And the farmer confirmed the story-- the entire thing, the boxes, the bung. But when I asked him to go on the record, to tape an interview, and gave his name here, on the radio, he very politely declined, which seems suspicious, right?
When I asked him why, he said he'd spoken with his girlfriend about it, and she suggested that he should think about the words that he wanted to come up when somebody Googled his name. This was all fine, though, because he referred me to the real expert, the guy who gave him the tour of the hog processing plant. And that guy, he agreed to talk.
[PHONE RINGING]
Hello.
Hi, is this Ron?
Yeah.
Yeah, this is Ron Meek, meat processing plant manager, presently residing in Mountain View, Missouri, where he runs an organic beef processing plant there called Beyond Organic. If the story really were true, Ron would have been the guy who explained to the farmer what was in those boxes.
The boxes are 10-pound boxes, and they were all-- they cut off so much of it, maybe a 10- or 12-inch piece of the bung. And you know what it looks like? This looks like, after they're cleaned and washed and everything, they just look like a bunch of big noodles in a box, is all it looks like.
But specifically, the labels that said "imitation calamari," where did you personally see the "imitation calamari?"
Oh, I've seen a label say that. That's all I was told by the people that told me that. The people I work for, they told me that.
Oh, the people that you worked for told you that it was used for imitation calamari?
Right.
And is there any possibility that you think that when they were explaining this to you, that they were kind of having you on a little bit?
Having me on?
Yeah, like--
Bull-[BLEEP] me?
Yeah.
Well, I wouldn't think that. But it could be 5%. It could have been that. But I seriously doubt it.
OK, just to give a little better picture, a pork bung-- and "bung" is the actual industry term for it-- is long and floppy and ugly. At one end, it widens out into this more bulbous shape, like a pink, wrinkly pear. That's the rectum. At the other end, it narrows into a soft, pinkish-white tube.
I know, it sounds gross. But also, consider, we are a nation that eats more than a billion pounds of sausage every year, billion with a B. Maybe you like liverwurst or capicola or summer sausage with a natural casing. Then you, like me, have eaten bung-- stuffed, dried bung.
A lot of brats and Italian sausages are stuffed in intestine. So if you eat those regularly, you pretty much live up the street from bung. So why does the idea of a fried ring of bung just feel grosser? Well, partly, it's the visual, right? When you see that little ring of calamari, you don't want to picture it in the context of a pig's behind.
Then there are all the people who don't eat pork, period. Ron said there's also another reason.
Just because of the word "bung," probably. I mean, people don't just want to jump up and say, man, I'm going to eat me some bung tonight. I mean, that's just the way it is.
But the big question, the question you've been thinking about since we got on this topic, have you or I eaten imitation calamari, bung dressed up as seafood? Well, Ron didn't know. He said his plant exported a lot of their bung to Asia. But he just didn't know much about whatever happened after it left the door. So he could only speculate. Anything, he said, would be a wild guess.
So I turned to people who would know. Is pork bung being falsely peddled as calamari? I called the USDA. The USDA's Food Inspection Service issued the following statement to me. "Products we inspect, including those derived from pork, must be accurately labeled and cannot purport to be a product of another species."
So it's against the rules. But people break the rules. A recent study of seafood by a group called Oceana used DNA testing, and found that all across the country, fish is regularly being labeled as other species in restaurants and in grocery stores, escolar sold as white tuna, Pacific rockfish being fraudulently sold as snapper.
In Miami, more than 30% of fish was being sold as something it wasn't. In New York, the number was 39%, Boston, 48%, Los Angeles-- are you ready? 55%, 55. That means if you order fish in LA, you are most likely eating a species you did not order.
In other words, seafood substitution is rampant in this country. And depending on where you live, from what I can tell, you can get cleaned hog bung for about half the price of clean squid. So there would be money in it if you could pull off the switch. And as best as I can tell, were you to do this, you would not be caught.
A lawyer who's familiar with this area of law and regulation told me, once bung leaves the plant, there's a variety of agencies and entities that would be in play-- USDA, FDA, state, and local government. But ultimately, he said, the regulation we have is not designed to catch an offense like this. It's aimed mostly at sanitation and food safety.
So bottom line, the lawyer said, if somebody wanted to do it, chances are, they'd get away with it. So is someone out there doing this? Well, for weeks, I looked for an answer. The USDA says they've never heard of anyone trying to pass pork bung as squid or any other species.
[PHONE RINGING]
I contacted the National Restaurant Association, the National Pork Producers Council, the National Pork Board--
Hello?
--a squid fisherman's association--
Good afternoon.
--Cisco and other big food and restaurant supply companies.
It's hog what?
Bung, hog rectum.
Oh, my gosh.
That's the executive director of the California Wet Fish Producers Association. But the answer was pretty much always the same, nobody had heard of it. But almost to a person, they added that that doesn't mean it's not happening somewhere.
Ron Meeks said a lot of the bung from his plant got exported. So my next call was to the US Meat Export Federation, which confirmed that, quote, "the main destinations for pork bungs are China, Hong Kong, Japan, Taiwan, Korea, and the Philippines. They are mainly used for processing. But we are aware of some uses in soups and certain entrees. We are not aware of them being used as a substitute for calamari, but it's not impossible," unquote.
So over the past few weeks, I've called Asian food suppliers, people who live in, work in, and eat in those countries. I talked to a woman named Corinne Trang, who's written an overarching compendium of Asian cuisines. I've talked to academics at NYU and Haverford and USC and Harvard. I've reached out to chefs who know Asian food.
The answer, again, always similar-- never heard of it, but it's possible, partly because bung doesn't have such a complicated reputation in Asia, where it has to be some kind of secret ingredient, like it does here. On the other hand, though, people pointed out that in Korea and Japan, you can't get more than a few hours from the ocean. Squid is cheap and it's readily available. You'd only eat a substitute if you wanted the substitute.
Generally, people said, if the switch was happening somewhere, they'd guess China. Eventually, I found my way to this guy, who I was really excited about, someone who I thought might have my answer. He was, get this, an anthropologist who lived and worked in China for 40 years, where he studied food, and specifically, meat.
When I talked to him, though, he made two points. Point one, my question about this happening in Asia was racist. Even just asking the question was racist because it plays on ignorant stereotypes about other cultures eating things that we perceive as weird. Point two was that Ron Meek, my guy from the pig plant, Ron was pulling my leg. And he was getting away with it because I was a dumbass.
He told me more than once that I should, quote, "find something worthwhile to do with myself." When we ended our conversation, he told me that he was refusing to even dignify what I was doing by appearing on the radio or by letting me use his name.
OK, so to respond to his points one by one, first, am I racist against Asians? Well, I'm half Chinese. My mom's Chinese. Like anyone, I've had the occasional issue with my mother. But this has not been one of them. We grew up eating chicken feet and fish eyes. And I think it's possible to raise the question of who eats what without being racist.
His second point, though, that Ron Meek was pulling my leg, I mean, the guy was still an expert on meat in China. So I called Ron back.
All right, shoot me some questions, dude.
I told him the whole thing, about the anthropologist, about what he said.
I guess, I mean, the only thing I want to ask you is, are you messing with me?
No. I mean, that was what my boss told me. I was like, what the hell do we save these hog bungs for? He says they use them for imitation squids and stuff like that.
So in your heart of hearts, you believe it?
Yeah, man, I mean, I ain't going to sit here and tell you things that, they're just bull-[BLEEP], and play with you, when I'm just going off of my knowledge of saving hog bungs. I mean, you got to think about how far advanced slaughterhouses are, especially big ones, that want to make every penny count.
The one I worked at, you bring the pigs in, you stun them, then you stick them, and the blood goes off into a trough, and it goes down. And it's vacuum sucked out of there with a vacuum, into centrifuges. And they separate the blood from the blood plasma. And they save that.
I mean, they save the lungs. They save the pancreas. They save the spleens. They save the hearts. The only thing left, by the time it's all said and done, is a skull and jawbones. I mean, you can be an anthropologist all you want. And if you don't work in a processing plant, you don't know [BLEEP].
I contacted the plant Ron worked at, where this happened. And for what it's worth, they backed him up. They said their sales team had heard of people eating pork bung as imitation calamari, though they hadn't witnessed it firsthand or heard it directly from a customer. It was all hearsay.
So at the end of all this, I still had no proof that anyone was passing off bung as squid. And then I realized I hadn't asked the more basic question here. Could bung do it? Could it pass as calamari? And that question led me to a guy named Eddie Lin. Eddie Lin has eaten a lot of bung, at least a hundred times, he said, probably more. Eddie has an extreme food blog called "Deep-End Dining" and an online TV show called Kamikaze Kitchen.
I can definitely see a resemblance, texture-wise.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah, definitely. There's a rubbery texture, sort of like a calamari.
Huh.
But you would really have to get rid of that, needless to say, foul flavor and odor from the bung.
Somehow, I hadn't figured that the bung, once it was scrubbed and rinsed and cleaned with steam, that it would still taste like, you know.
So yeah, you would definitely have to do some major, major blanching-- or brining. I meant brining.
Uh-huh, to just to try and leach those flavors out of there?
Yeah, I mean, those flavors have been marinating in that pig for quite a while. So--
A lifetime?
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
He thought it wouldn't be easy, but he thought it could be done. And there was only one way to tell if he was right, to cook up some bung and eat it. And if the taste was overwhelming and the texture was all wrong, well, then I'd have my answer. And at this point, I'll be frank, I started to root for the bung.
I realized that this is not a story about fraud. It's not a bait-and-switch story. It's a story about possibility. It's classic rags to riches. It's about whether a cut of meat, perhaps the lowliest, most malignable cut of meat in America, might somehow, in at least one place on the planet, be dipped in the redemptive oils of the great culinary equalizer that is the deep fryer. And it might emerge transformed, no longer an outcast, but instead, hair combed, clean-shaven, in a suit and tie. It might walk reborn onto a table.
Through sheer force of resemblance, it might be loved, its history, years of drudgery and hardship, doing the body's least glamorous job, all washed away. No, this is not the story of a con man like Bernie Madoff. It's Pretty Woman. This is whether Good Will Hunting finds his way out of Southie. It's whether Charlie, on that very last chocolate bar, really can get a golden ticket.
To do all this, to try it, I called my little sister, Lauren. She's a chef, trained abroad at The Cordon Bleu, worked at Michelin-star restaurants. She's that kind of chef. Soon, we were standing in front of a deli case. And I don't know why I feel hesitant about saying this because I don't think it's racist. It was in Chinatown.
Pork bung, there it is. Look at it, it looks like a sphincter.
Wait, what do you mean, it looks like a--
This one up here, that's cut up, it looks like a butt hole.
[LAUGHS]
It does.
And Lauren had theories about pulling it off-- brining, soaking, maybe braising. But once we got to the store, once she'd seen the meat up close, her doubts got worse.
I think, after looking at it, I don't think it's going to--
You don't think it's going to work?
No. It's too thick. There's too much muscle tissue. It's too thick. You'd have to use a ring cutter to make it the right thickness.
What do you think those bits are, in there?
Oh, you know, poo.
My sister said Eddie Lin was definitely right. The giveaway would be the stubborn flavor of poo. That flavor, she said, it's tough to get rid of. The Earth revolves around the sun. And bung will always taste like [BLEEP].
But there was no backing out now. We would eat. We would eat our way to the truth. And so what if it didn't look good? So what if bung was destined to taste like bung? You know who it didn't look good for, and he still put up a fight? Rocky Balboa, that's who. This was it, the bung versus calamari, squid versus tail, The Rumble in the Bunghole.
We set up the tasting at a restaurant, in the lull between lunch and dinner. In the dining room, there was just a few tables eating. And all around the restaurant, the morning shift was wrapping up as we walked in with a red cooler filled with squid and hog bung.
So originally, I'd recruited some half a dozen people from our office at This American Life as tasters. The final group the day of the tasting included, from the office, Seth Lind and Brian Reed.
So when's the last time that you guys had calamari?
I had calamari probably a month ago.
And what about you, Brian?
I haven't had it since we got this tip about the possible--
Oh, my gosh, have you been avoiding?
Yeah, no, totally. And to be honest, I ate calamari pretty regular. I'm a regular eater of calamari-- not all the time, but it's something I'll routinely order if it's on an appetizer menu.
Yeah.
I mean, I grew up in an Italian-American family, where my grandparents were also born here. I feel like calamari is just big among that sector of people, at Olive Garden and stuff like that. So I just grew up eating it.
I hadn't realized this. For weeks, Brian had been avoiding calamari. He'd been living in fear.
Brian, if you find out that they're indiscernible from each other, will you ever eat calamari again?
No, I don't think so. That's why I want to do this, just to know, going forward.
Back in the kitchen, things were looking bad. I'd given up on the idea that bung would taste the same as calamari. Now I'd hung my hopes on the idea that at least visually, it would look the same. But as my sister dropped the flowered rings of hog bung into the fryer, they had turned into this kind of big, ugly, tangled wad, nothing like the jiggly squid rings.
Oh, they're very scraggly-looking.
But then, as if by a miracle, they changed. My sister gave a shake to the fry basket, and as they sizzled, the bung just seemed to gracefully snap into rings.
Oh, look at that, though. It's like magic. They're turning into circles.
Yeah. So I'm going to pull these first ones.
Soon, we were face to face with the plate. On it, there were two piles of rings, similar in size, similar in shape. The bung had more of a frizzly edge to it, kind of like a fancy onion ring. The calamari was smoother.
OK, so--
I asked Seth and Brian to just give a first impression.
I have a guess. But it's one of those things where you're pretty sure, but you could totally be wrong.
God, I thought I would be more sure. I don't-- I'm waffling now. My gut reaction is that this was calamari and this was not.
OK, before you eat it, see, I totally thought this was calamari, the other one.
OK.
So I'm going to do it at the same time.
OK, so just to be clear what's going on here, Seth has chosen one pile of rings which he thinks is calamari. Brian has done the same thing, only Brian is choosing the other stack of fried rings.
OK, so we're about to bite into these simultaneously, which we both think this is calamari.
But they're the opposite ones.
The opposite ones. OK.
[CRUNCHING]
So in actuality, Seth is right. Seth is eating calamari. The chewing you hear from Brian's mic, that is the sound of a calamari lover eating fried pig rectum. I should also add there were actually two varieties of bung on the plate that day, one bung that my sister had blanched over and over to mellow any organ-y, fecal flavor, and then untreated, straight-up bung, unfiltered, unchained, uncut, 100% pure bung. That one, the latter one, bung at its purest, at the height of its bunginess, this is what Brian was eating. As they ate, Seth still looked confident.
I think I was right.
(LAUGHING) I think I was right.
Really?
Yeah. I totally think I was right.
Game, set, match, bung. And it wasn't just Brian. I thought so. Damien, who manages the restaurant, he also thought it was passable. A few of us picked up a faint flavor of pork rind, but if you weren't really looking for it, you wouldn't notice it was there. One of the restaurant staff, a guy named Ethan Vanburen, had the simplest, clearest explanation.
I think that when you slice something up really thin and deep fry it, it's going to taste like something that's been deep fried.
If a plate full of the bung came out, how many people do you think would even-- do you think you'd notice if you were in that setting?
I'd say top scenario is somebody says, this calamari tastes funny, and keeps eating it.
And as for Brian-- oh, Brian-- Brian was reeling a bit, trying to figure out just what this was going to mean for him.
I'm sure I've been fooled in the past. I'm just, like, sure of it.
Wait, oh, you're thinking that you've been places in the past, and you've had bung?
I just imagined seeing a plate with this food, that looks like this on it, sitting with my family, growing up. We definitely have eaten something that tasted like this, and just thought it was calamari, for sure.
Not only wasn't he sure if he'd ever eat calamari again, he didn't want to eat the calamari on the plate in front of him, calamari I guaranteed him, was real.
Just to repeat one last time, I have no proof that anyone, anywhere, has ever tried to pass off pork bung as calamari in a restaurant. All I know is, if you wanted to do it, it would be easy. And I'm choosing to believe that it's happening somewhere, because at some point in working on this story, I stopped identifying with Brian and anyone who might feel ripped off or grossed out by getting imitation instead of the real thing.
Now, I identify with the bung. I'd like to think that somewhere out there, right now, under a heat lamp, a platter is sitting. It's warm, and it's full of promise and transformation and redemption. That's the world that I'll choose to live in for me, for you, for the bung. For the bung in all of us.
Ben Calhoun, he's one of the producers of our program.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Ben Calhoun, he's one of the producers of our program. Thanks to the restaurant Aurora, in Brooklyn, for letting us use their kitchen for our taste test.
OK.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) OK, who is this? Wait, who am I?
Well, coming up, Philadelphia and Afghanistan, doppelgangers?
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) So we're going to start act 2?
Start here. So we're coming back from the ID break.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme. We bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, doppelgangers, stories of things that have a double, an evil twin, or a not-so-evil twin.
Oh, wait, I should just explain. Oh, right, so--
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) What?
That was just a note to myself. I should explain.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) No, that was a note to me.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is why Fred is here. Fred Armisen is co-hosting the show as me because it's a show about doubles and lookalikes.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Right, but we're both creating the same person, in a sense. And that's what the fun is of--
Oh, that was really good, the way you just did that.
[LAUGHS]
Finish your thought.
I didn't have an end to that thought. I just--
You just knew that--
I like when you do the little self-- the little discovery.
All right, well, we have arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, In Country and City. So for decades now, the writer Alex Kotlowitz has been writing about the inner cities, and especially the toll of violence on young people. He's probably best known for his book, There Are No Children Here. He appears on our show from time to time.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Recently, he heard about an unusual program at Drexel University in Philadelphia, where they're giving guys from inner city neighborhoods counseling for symptoms of PTSD.
And this interested Alex, because for a long time, he has wondered whether the violence that he was reporting on in Chicago and its effect on kids and adults was comparable to the effects of trauma that a person experiences at war.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) So he knew, and we know, how strange that sounds, to compare being in Afghanistan or Iraq to working a street corner in Chicago or some other city.
So Alex tried to see if it was really comparable by doing a pair of interviews. He talked to this vet from Afghanistan and also a guy from Philadelphia, who's lived in some pretty bad neighborhoods his whole life. Alex wanted to see if they were doubles of some kind for each other.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) One of these guys is 28, one is 30, and both of them are trying to make sense of what they experienced. Here's Alex.
Here's the first of these two guys, Brandon Caro. Brandon spent a year in Afghanistan. His roughest time was the six months he spent in the eastern part of the country, near the Pakistani border. He was a Navy corpsman, a medic who worked with the Marines.
As a teenager, yeah, I certainly lacked discipline. I had been thrown out of my house more times than I can remember. And I was 21 when I enlisted. And really, I enlisted because I had, up to that point, not finished college. And it didn't seem as though I was going to finish college any time soon.
Then there's Curtis Jefferson. He grew up in a rough neighborhood in North Philly, where he oversaw a small group of guys who sold drugs. He made his first drug sale when he was still in high school.
I was 16. My aunt gave me some money for school. And that point, I purchased some weed and some crack with that, never bought my clothes. After that, I sold all the drugs. And I guess from there, that's where it started. I seen that money come in, and I wasn't asking nobody for no money. Especially with my aunt, I wasn't begging for from her pockets and all that. So from there, it was all she wrote.
OK, they're two completely different people who made very different choices in their lives. But I spoke to each of them, looking for similarities in their experiences. And honestly, there were more than I expected. Here's the first similarity.
For Curtis on the street, and for Brandon in Afghanistan, they could never let their guard down. During his tour, Brandon was charged with training Afghan soldiers. And in May 2007, he heard about Afghan soldiers who attacked their American trainers.
They had weapons around us all the time. On convoys, we would have to line him up in the morning and collect their cell phones because we couldn't trust them not to inform on us to Taliban fighters. It was exhausting, trying to keep an eye on the Afghan soldiers and look out for IEDs or snipers.
Because you're trying to focus on one thing, you're trying to get money, but the same thing, eventually, somebody's going to come up and test you. Somebody's going to test you. Somebody's going to rob you. Somebody's going to send something to your boys, they're going to get robbed. Somebody's going to send shots your way or something.
It felt like a piano could fall on you at any time. That's what it felt like to be on patrol, and especially to be on patrol with the Afghans.
Because when you're out there, you notice different things-- for one, people with their hands in their pockets.
You're looking for someone that doesn't look right, that doesn't feel right.
Another thing, people who've got hoodies on, especially black. There's a certain look, put the hoodie on their face, you can't even see their eyeballs. Come on, it's daytime. I can't see your face. Let me see your eyes or something.
And I would watch the way they looked at me, If they would stare back at me, if they would smile at me.
If a person always got to keep touching their side, you're not going in your pocket, you're touching something. And I've been out there so long, I could tell if somebody's got a gun on them or not.
For some reason, it was always a white Toyota Camry that was packed with explosives and driven into a convoy, or driven into a checkpoint.
Grand Marquis, or what else? Crown Victoria, that's a dope-boy car. When I seen them cars when I was on the streets, it was either get ready, go for the straps, go to the guns, or get out of the way. That might be the hop-out boys, come stick you up.
Here's something else they shared. They both saw people killed, and then had to figure out how to keep going. The first fatality Brandon ever saw came when a convoy, which he was originally scheduled to be a part of, was hit.
They brought the casualties into our base. And when we swung open the two doors that opened up into the cab of the truck, I was looking at just a heap, a mass of flesh, and that gray, digital-pattern Army uniform. But there was no form to what I was looking at. I knew that what I was looking at was human. But I didn't know what position the body was in because it had been so badly damaged.
And so we got into the cab and we started to put him into a bag. And I tried not to look at his face. I remember thinking, don't look at his face, don't look at his face. But I had to, inevitably. It was by far, the most intimate, goriest thing I've ever experienced in my life.
My first time seeing somebody shot was my own mother. I was five years old, going on six. We were living in the projects, Blumberg projects. My mom, she just got her degree in nursing. She was a nurse, had a nice little job. She was working to get us out of the projects.
Then one morning, she was going out to work, gave my mom a kiss on the lips, and she told my grandma, I'll see y'all later. I'm going to work. As soon as she went out to work, I just heard all this shooting. By that time, I knew what shooting was. But there it was. She just got caught up in a shootout.
Somebody knocked on the door. She told my grandma, she said, Barbara's laying on the ground. All I know is my grandma was screaming and hollering. And she ran outside. And there she was, right on the ground, just red blood, just nothing but blood.
Just looking at it her, I'm five years old, like, what's wrong with Mommy, Grandma? What's wrong with her? My grandma's crying and screaming. She didn't even say nothing. She just keep telling me, go in the house, go in the house, go in the house.
I was angry a lot, every day, every day, because I thought about my mom, every day, every day, every day. I still think about her every day.
From that point on, it was very difficult for me to sleep, to focus. I didn't realize how much those things really had made an impact on me, but they did.
I seen a lot of people get shot. I seen people get shot by cops. And I seen best friends shoot each other. I seen all types of crazy stuff. I don't know.
There was a convoy that went up to Naray, in which there was a sniper attack that killed my old sergeant and his sergeant. There was the rocket-propelled grenade attack on a tent, inside our FOB, followed up by machine-gun fire.
[SIGHS] I could say I had seen a dozen. And for me to not even be like no cop or no doctor or nothing, that's a whole lot to see somebody killed and dead. That's a whole lot.
This brings us to the third parallel, they buried their feelings.
Well, after my mom got shot, I didn't get no counseling. I didn't get no counselor at all. And my aunt asked me, too. My aunt gave me a decision. And she asked me one day. I had to have been, like, 12. She was like, do you want to go to counseling? And I told her, no, for what? I don't need to talk to nobody. I was so much in denial. I think I can handle everything by myself, but I really couldn't.
I think at that point, I was probably still in denial. I knew that I was toting around a lot of emotional baggage. As much as I wanted to talk to people about how I really felt, I also didn't want to talk about it at all. The more I'd give it air, the more real it would be. And I didn't want it to be real. I just wanted it to be over.
I can't show no weakness because, you know what I mean? My homies need me out there. And I've been doing that for years. It's to the point, I started getting adapted to it, like, [BLEEP]. But at the same time, I was still scared. Don't nobody want to die like that.
The fourth shared experience-- raw, unfiltered rage.
I was definitely looking for revenge for my mom. When I was about 10 years old, I told my aunt I was going to look for the people that killed my mom. And I was going to go back down to the projects, and I was going to kill them. I always thought like that.
I mean, the way I felt about the Afghans, I began to just hate that whole culture, entirely. I hated them. There was one time, we were driving on an extremely, extremely dangerous road. And we had come very close to falling off the cliff, which would have killed us.
And the truck to our front was a truck filled with Afghan soldiers. And they were pointing and laughing at us for almost falling off. And in that moment, more than any other moment, I wanted to open up on them and kill every one of them. I've realized how much anger and resentment I have, and how dangerous that is.
Man, I shot my sister's boyfriend. I mean, he-- I don't know, I think I had one of them moments. It had to have been, because it just took one word, and it just set me off for no reason, just thinking about everything. And I just shot him.
I felt some type of way. I made the situation deeper, and it wasn't. You know what I mean? It wasn't even that deep. But I've been holding a lot of stuff in, because he was always trying to discipline me. That's what it was, I didn't like about it, how he always tried to discipline me.
All my sisters are way older than me, they're 40, pushing 50. See what I'm saying? I'm the youngest. And I'm the only boy. So her boyfriends, they're just, oh, you need to stop getting the streets. But it's just how he was saying it. Don't raise your voice at me. He's talking about, yeah, I'm going to take you in the street and fight you and all this. You're going to learn your lesson.
It just was the part where he was like, yeah, I'm going to knock you the [BLEEP] out. And that just went in my head, like, what? First thing I do is grab my gun and come around the corner. And he was outside, too. And I'm thinking the whole time, I hope he ain't really outside. So he thinks I'm going to fight him. I'm not fighting this man. I'm going to kill him.
I didn't even give him a chance to put his hands up. As soon as I got around there, he was just all in my face, and just backed up and shot him, shot him in the stomach. I thought I was going to kill him. I thought he was dead, though. I guess everything worked out in its ways. He's ain't a person to tell-- he ain't tell. He still survived, so I don't know.
Here's something I didn't expect with either of them. The toughest times weren't when they were on the battlefield or in the streets. It was when things were quiet. That's when they struggled the most.
The worst times, for me, were the times where we weren't out on patrol, because that's when I was alone with my thoughts. And I would try to clear my head. It was impossible. These thoughts would just appear. I would worry. I thought about what it would be like to be shot.
I might daydream, just look at my ceiling or something, watch TV, like, damn, just imagine bullets going, ripping through my body. You know, mother-[BLEEP] just come out with a gun, just start shooting everything. And I'm getting hit. Everybody getting hit.
I would think what it would feel like to be blown up in an IED, to be pinned down, and have the vehicle set ablaze, and to burn alive, to be trapped in the truck because the doors were too heavy to cut through or to pull open.
Seeing it like this, seeing it with my own eyes, just look, seeing blood, and me just falling to the ground, and is too late for the ambulance? Would I still be alive when the ambulance come get me? Or that crazy kind of stuff, like, when you sit and think about that stuff, that kind of stuff drives you crazy.
For both, reality eventually caught up to their fears. In the spring of 2006, Curtis told us he got caught in a shootout with rival drug dealers. The first bullet, to his back, spun him around. He got hit four more times, in the stomach and in the arm. As a result, he walks doubled over, like an old man. Because a permanent nerve damage, he falls a lot. And when he's under stress or eats the wrong food, he has bleeding from his intestines.
Brandon, too, was hurt in a rollover when his Humvee fell off a small cliff. Brandon had been manning the turret, and fortunately, another soldier pulled him in just as the vehicle rolled. He suffered three fractures of his vertebrae and two herniated disks, and the pain kept him up nights, even after he left Afghanistan.
Both men were on a lot of medications after their injuries. And our sixth similarity may not be so surprising-- they self-medicated.
I had started to drink again. And on the weekends, I would drink heavily.
It makes my body just feel a little better, like just a little basic, Mary Jane, that's all.
Usually a Crown and Coke was my drink of choice. And I would probably drink at least 5, up to 8, 9, 10 in the night.
But sometimes, it do give me the opposite effect.
When I was very, very drunk, I would start to cry because of how upset I was.
Because, you know, when I smoke, it put me on a mellow. Then, you know, you just start thinking. Then that's when all the thoughts just come, like, oh, what the hell they just come from? And I'd be like, oh, some thoughts I think sometimes, I don't want to think about.
Echo number seven, they lashed out at friends and family. Curtis had night terrors, and would wake in the middle of the night thinking his girlfriend was someone who was trying to shoot him. He'd push her. He'd hit her in the head. He'd call her names.
I just was like, dang, I know I'm hurting this girl. I'm really putting my hands on her, like a man, putting marks on her arms. And I said, I'm losing it. And I was like, shh.
Brandon had a difficult relationship with a girlfriend, too. They'd get into huge arguments and she'd get scared. One time, Brandon got so agitated, a friend intervened and tried to calm him down. Brandon punched him. His girlfriend locked herself in her room and called the police.
Police came. And I was inside. And the police rang the doorbell. And I opened it up. And it was two cops, a guy and a girl cop. And I asked the guy, is your weapon loaded? He said, why would you ask me something like that? I said, because I want you to shoot me in the head.
I was just sitting in my bedroom. And I had my gun under my bed, in a sneaker box. I had a 40 Mag, big, old cowboy gun. And that's when my grandma caught the gun in my mouth. Yeah, she just opened the door to make sure I was cool. It just was one of them days. She opened the door, and gun in my mouth, you know what I mean?
She didn't know what to do. She didn't know to come closer or stay back. She didn't know what to do. So she looking at me, start whooping and crying. And she didn't want to come next to me. And so she's just talking to me the whole time, like, come on, baby, it's all right, I love you. You're my grandson. You know, your mom ain't leave you out here on the Earth for this. You blessed. You just got shot five times. Why are you?
It's going to be all right. We're going to get some help for you and everything. And I just took it out, decocked it, put it back in the box, and just sat there. And called my homie up, and bring some weed around the corner, and got high. And that's how that went.
Both Brandon and Curtis have gotten help. Brandon's in AA and went through a writing program for veterans at NYU. Curtis is receiving counseling through the program at Drexel that offers help to guys coming off the street. But finally, it's here where their stories diverge. Brandon's tour ended, and he's now thousands of miles from the dangers of Afghanistan. Curtis still lives in his old neighborhood, where the danger's ongoing.
When I get more money, I'm definitely moving. I'm going to move. That's a priority I'm working on right now. I'm out. I'm going to live somewhere comfortable, that I know I can walk in the neighborhood, I could sit out there on my step all day, all night, if I want to.
Not long ago, a guy was shot and killed down the block from where he lives. And Curtis happened to see the body on the ground.
And I just was thinking about a lot of the-- I was paused. I just was like, yo, when he shot, like, damn, that boy was on the ground. And that was me. It's just, I'm living. Like, he died. And I'm like, damn. And it just felt like I felt all them bullets all over again.
Curtis worries that because of the way he walks, perpetually bent over, he looks weak and that people will target him, rob him, beat him up, shoot him, take revenge. I wonder, for someone like Curtis, if it's really post-traumatic stress, since really, there's nothing post about it.
Brandon, meanwhile, says he doesn't talk to his friends or family about his anger and his nightmares, which he still has regularly. He tried counseling, but didn't like it. So he sought out other veterans who understand what he's been through.
And Curtis now attends group counseling with others who, like himself, were once running the streets. That's the final echo. They've both come to realize that they're not alone.
Alex Kotlowitz.
His books and documentaries include, most recently, the film The Interrupters, which he wrote and co-produced, which is at iTunes, Netflix, Amazon, and on DVD.
OK, so should we do the credits?
Yeah, let's do it. Are you ready? God, you do this whole thing at the end of every show?
Yeah. OK. Ready?
You've got to hire someone to do that. (IMITATING IRA GLASS) Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek and myself--
With Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Our senior producer's Julie Snyder.
Production help from Tarek Fouda and Phia Bennin.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Seth Lind is our operations director.
Emily Condon's our production manager.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Special thanks today to Jack Chen, Marissa Gillette, Katie Conner.
Mat Hannigan, Mike Reed, Chris Waldrup, Damien Graef, his kitchen crew, and everyone who ate the bung.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Ted Corbin and Tony Thompson of the Healing Hurt People Program at Drexel University.
Nate Beaver, Amy Drozdowska.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Eleanora Monticella, Kevin Miller.
Zachary Sussman at NYU--
(BOTH) and Michelle Harris.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) Our website, where for the first time ever, you can watch the videotape of the Saturday Night Live dress rehearsal of me doing Ira Glass.
That address, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia.
After a hard day at the radio station, he always declares on his way out the door--
I'm Ira Glass.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) And I'm Ira Glass.
He's actually Fred Armisen, by the way. Portlandia season 3, that's Friday nights?
On IFC.
IFC season 3, back next week with more stories of
(BOTH) This American Life.
[SAMMY DAVIS, JR., "ME AND MY SHADOW"]
OK, I think we're done. And I think we should cut.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) I think we are, I think-- are we OK?
I think we're OK.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) I'm not too worried about it.
I think we got it.
(IMITATING IRA GLASS) I wouldn't worry about it.
Say, Frank?
What is it, Sam?
Would you do me a favor?
What do you want now?
Would you mind just taking it one more time?
From the top?
No, from the ending.
Wonderful.
PRI Public Radio International.